all right what's going on guys this is
rob and this is our easter eggs video
honestly we haven't done a lot of these
like tried and true easter egg videos
but we're gonna give it a shot we're
gonna see how this goes see whether or
not you guys enjoy it or not so there
were all kinds of easter eggs and
callbacks in this movie and it was it
was great to see a lot of these little
little small moments right so let's kind
of start at the top from the things that
we noticed and work our way down to the
things that other people noticed that we
actually didn't catch that we wanted to
incorporate in this video so the first
two are not overly fantastic or crazy or
anything like that but there was a
poster for the rogers musical and then
delmar's deli is back which is kind of a
cool little thing rogers musical of
course is a musical that i really wish
existed in real life that i would
definitely go see the musical talking
about steve rogers and like the avengers
and all that kind of stuff and then del
mar's deli is a nice little call back
because that was a place from spider-man
homecoming that apparently had the best
sandwiches in town that was ultimately
destroyed and then of course it's been
rebuilt and now it's back so that's kind
of a cool little thing but another thing
about this are what are basically the
edith glasses for those of you guys who
recall that the little glasses that were
given to uh spider-man by nick fury that
allowed him to tap into tony stark's
private network and like his weapons and
all that kind of stuff of course those
don't work in the movie because of
everything going on right now and the
fact that tony stark's entire network
has basically been shut down by the
federal government but then you've also
got this crazy thing that like net leads
can use magic now this is a reference to
the symbiote spider-man alien reality
storyline when nedley was the hobgoblin
and was actually a student of dormammu
so he learned how to use some measure of
magic whether or not marvel studios
chooses to do anything with this i'm not
entirely sure but it was a cool little
reference so that's pulled from the
comics it's not something the marvel
cinematic universe just made up off the
top of their head so a cool little
tidbit there now feast also exists in
the marvel cinematic universe now right
the food emergency aid shelter and
training facility and that was actually
started by martin lee now some of you
guys may have heard of martin lee some
of you guys may have not heard of martin
lee the importance of his character is
that martin lee was the good guy but his
alter ego was mr negative and feast was
actually being used by martin lee and
his henchmen the inner demons in order
to operate a criminal enterprise like it
was literally a front now eventually it
was shut down after everything that was
going on with martin lee and all that
kind of stuff and then eventually aunt
may reopened it on her own but it is
cool to see here because for those of
you guys who are familiar with a lot of
the the the kind of information that's
been going on out there with spider-man
no way home that feast was also a part
of the miles morales and spider-man
games for the ps4 but the other reason
why this is really cool is because for
those of you guys who are familiar with
a lot of the information that's going on
out there that tom holland has said
there's going to be ps4 related content
in this that will lead into bigger
things when it comes to the mcu and that
in the ps4 games you had feast and that
while peter parker had a hand in that
miles morales did as well and that
actually leads us to another easter egg
here one miles morales is never
officially name dropped in the movie but
there is a point where jamie foxx sees
what andrew garfield looks like a
spider-man for the first time in this
movie and then believed that he was
black and then makes an offhand remark
and saying there's got to be a black
spider-man out there somewhere so while
we don't get a name drop from miles
morales it's the second time the mcu has
referenced the concept of his character
we know he exists in the mcu because
like donald glover's character was like
i have a nephew he lives here and we
know that like that was uncle aaron
right so he's referencing miles morales
but it is cool to see another point to
the idea that miles morales is coming
now during the fight scene between peter
parker and doctor strange there's a
point where the cape wraps itself around
peter parker of course this is a direct
reference to the events of what if where
peter parker got the uh got the cloak of
spider-man during the zombies what if
episode but it's also a reference to
multiple what-if stories where peter
parker in some variation became a source
for supreme or something along those
lines or just gained the powers of
doctor strange regardless it's a nice
little easter egg kind of a throwback to
some of the projects that marvel's
already working on as well as some of
the stories that marvel's already done
now one of the other cool things if you
noticed is that when all the villains
are in the apartment of happy hogan
there's actually a really tender moment
that's shared between aunt may and
doctor octopus this is a reference to
the old spider-man comics where dr
octopus had almost married on me now he
did this for the purpose of basically
stealing an island that she inherited
but it was a great story right well the
two of them kind of had a bit of a
romantic connection that actually goes
all the way back to the days of sinister
six when dr octopus had kidnapped aunt
may but it treated her so well she
didn't even know she was being kidnapped
in the first place now of course no
romance is going to be brewing between
the two because he goes back to his
universe and she dies but it's still a
great little thing here in terms of of
these various characters kind of meeting
each other and and having a little
tender moment this sort of harkens back
to the marvel comic story lines
themselves now one of the other things
this is something that a lot of you guys
called is that during the graveyard huge
battle when you have mj who's knocked
off the scaffolding and she's saved by
spider-man the hand you see in terms of
it reaching down trying to grab her that
is tom holland that's tom holland
grabbing her the funny thing about this
is tom holland is basically knocked out
of the way by the green goblin and
ultimately mj is saved by andrew
garfield now this of course is a
reference to the death of gwen stacy
played by emma stone and the amazing
spider-man that so it was basically the
film giving andrew garfield a way to
basically make up for what he perceived
to be his biggest failure which was the
death of gwen stacy so it's cool it's
basically a little bit of a redemption
arc for his character now there is also
a moment in the movie which i don't
think a lot of people caught this when
toby mcguire makes a makes a kind of
comment to andrew garfield that like his
back hurts and andrew garfield was like
yeah man i've got a middle back thing
too he's like you owe me the crack
before he's like yeah sure this is a
reference to the events the real world
events that happened between spider-man
1 and spider-man 2 with tobey maguire
where he sustained a back injury and so
it's just kind of hitting back to that
little that little tidbit thing there
plus like toby maguire's old right old
man toby like old old old toby like it's
it's cool to see right he's just kind of
an older guy now right at least he's
kind of seen some things you know he's
like a dad you know and so on and so
forth it's cool i think it's kind of a
funny little thing right he has to have
his back crack and i thought it was just
funny that andrew garfield was the one
who cracked his back form i thought it
was a was a hilarious little thing and
in fact what i want to do here because
there were a lot of easter eggs and
references here i want to kind of
sidetrack and sort of move into the
territory of like toby and andrew and
tom and kind of talk about all their
different little little you know easter
eggs and references and whatnot so one
of the cool little things i don't know
this is really an easter egg so much as
just an observation is that uh the
various spider-man right andrew tom and
toby kind of talk about the different
villains they faced off against over the
years the more you like listen to their
conversation the more you realize just
how little andrew garfield actually did
aside from watching his girlfriend die
like there just wasn't much for him
right like toby's like yeah man i fought
like a black alien goo substance thing
and like tom hall's like yeah man i felt
like a giant purple alien and andrew's
like i didn't fight any of those i'm
just
just you know chilled or whatever it's
like that meme where tom holland and
toby are like hey andrew garfield do you
want to hear a joke and he's like yeah
and they're like trilogy and he's like i
didn't get it they're like exactly and
he's like
i don't know i don't know if i don't
know if i'm doing that meme justice but
it's like that right it's just it's it's
it's really really cool to see him
interacting and and how he stands in
relation to the other two spiderman but
he's also got his benefits like one of
the funny things that he and tom holland
share is they don't have organic webs so
they're just like flabbergasted by the
fact that like toby maguire has organic
webs and they don't and they're like do
you have any idea how useful that would
be just those small little things which
are really cool but another observation
slash easter egg that i noticed is that
tom holland and toby maguire and andrew
garfield actually all represent
spider-man at different points in
spider-man's life cycle so to speak that
that if you look at the spider-man no
way home film that they all kind of
represent who will become right that tom
holland is the young naive spider-man
right i mean he's reckless and doesn't
fully grasp the significance of what it
is that he's doing and he's having fun
as much as he's like i mean yeah i mean
people could get hurt but like
everything's okay because you know we're
superheroes the day's always gonna be
saved and then andrew garfield
represents the jaded aspect of tom holm
which is to say when tom holland
basically lost aunt may when he was dark
and he was he was angry in the movie
andrew garfield's like after gwen stacy
died i became hardcore i stopped pulling
my punches now of course that line is a
direct easter egg reference to superior
spider-man when doctor octopus took over
the body of peter and then when he
fought the scorpion he punched his jaw
off his face and realized that peter
parker had actually been holding his
punches or pulling his punches all those
years and was never fighting his
villains with his full strength
otherwise he would have beat them to
death right so that's that little easter
egg going on there but again andrew
garfield represents the darker jaded
side of peter and then toby represents
the version of peter who kind of has it
all figured out so it's sort of like the
three-step process right that tom
holland he represents himself in the
beginning and then midway through after
the death of aunt may he's represented
by andrew garfield and then at the end
toby represents tom holland which is
coming to terms with what it means to
really be a superhero and finding
balance so they're not there arbitrarily
i mean yes they are there for fan
service right we were all happy to see
them but they serve as much of a
metaphysical role as they do an actual
role in the movie so it was really cool
to see that kind of thing play out of
course we do also get the meme right the
sam raimi meme that all you guys love so
much right well we get a few of those
right there's one where uh where norman
osborne is like well i'm something of a
scientist myself
and then of course you get the comment
from dr octopus where it's like the
power of the sun in the palm of my hand
right you get those memes but then you
also get the really really funny
spider-man meme from the old 1960s
cartoon show with all the spider-man
pointing at each other because there's
one point where they're all in the lab
and ned lee's is like hey peter and like
they all look up and they're like huh
what peter and they're like what that
peter which which peter and they're all
pointing at each other right so you get
that great moment which i'm glad we saw
there was no way john watts was going to
leave that out but it was a hilarious
moment right it was it was one of those
things where the the little easter eggs
and the little things you get are pretty
cool because the final easter egg that i
really want to talk about here is a ps4
easter egg and it's one of the things
that again you know you had kind of a
maneuver that was done by peter towards
the end which was a ps4 style move right
a move that you saw peter do in the ps4
game but another pull from the ps4 game
is aunt may's tombstone that in the game
it said when you help someone you help
everyone the exact same inscription is
written on her tombstone in the film so
you know really heavily carrying over
the idea of the ps4 uh franchise and
that's really an important thing here
because i feel like that leads into one
of the biggest easter eggs in the
entirety of this of this movie which is
they're drawing a lot from the
playstation 4 game and while i wouldn't
say the playstation 4 game is going to
serve as the entire foundation by which
the future spider-man movies are made i
would not be surprised if they drew
heavily on the ps4 game right so the
introduction of miles morales officially
in the marvel cinematic universe comes
from his introduction in the playstation
games i wouldn't be surprised if that
was the case there's a lot of
similarities there right like and not
even just in terms of just things that
exist right like feast existing or like
aunt may's tombstone but in terms of
like the feel of the movie versus the
feel of the game especially when you're
at the end when peter fully becomes
spider-man goes forward does his own
thing with the world not knowing his
real identity it's cool but that's our
video for easter eggs let us know what
you guys think down in the comments
section if there's any that we missed
anything that we should have talked
about and yeah thank you guys for
watching and we will catch you all later
peace